Chris: IT'S TIME TO PLAY
ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE.
AFTER RETURNING FROM
AN RECENT TRIP TO ENGLAND,
66-YEAR-OLD FLORIDIAN
SCOTT WATERS POSTED A LIST OF
99 ADORABLE OBSERVATIONS ABOUT
HIS VISIT. AND IT MADE ALL OF
BRITAIN PUT DOWN THEIR GRAVY
SANDWICHES, AND COLLECTIVELY
SIGH, "HE GETS US. HE REALLY
[BEEP]IN' GETS US."
WITH CUTE, EXTREMELY OBVIOUS
LITTLE NOTES LIKE:
"ROADS ARE THE SIZE OF OUR
SIDEWALKS AND
CAKE IS ONE OF THE MAJOR
FOOD GROUPS.
HIS POST HAS BEEN SHARED OVER
50,000 TIMES OF BRITISH FOOTBALL
MOMS IN YOGA TROUSERS.
AND I'M CURIOUS WHAT HIS ENGLISH
COUNTERPART MIGHT OBSERVE ABOUT
AMERICA.
COMEDIANS, AS A 66-YEAR-OLD
BRITISH FACEBOOK USER, PLEASE
GIVE ME A LIST OF OBSERVATIONS
YOU'D MAKE ABOUT YOUR TRIP TO
THE STATES. IN 60 SECONDS, AND
BEGIN.
>> THEY HAVE A FASCINATING DISH
CALLED A SALAD.
IT'S MOSTLY LEAVES.
>> Chris: POINTS.
TOM.
>> THEIR LORD AND SAVIOR IS
KNOWN AS BEYONCE.
>> Chris: THANK YOU, MRS.
DOUBTFIRE. KURT.
>> THE BOBBIES SAY "CHIM-CHUREE"
BY SHOOTING YOU.
>> THEY HAVE STRANGE THINGS
CALLED DENTISTS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
Chris: KURT.
>> THEY CALL A DUST BIN A
TRASHCAN.
AND A TRASHCAN, KATY PERRY.
>> I LOVE KATY PERRY.
Chris: TOM LENK.
>> THEIR KING SERVES CHICKEN
FRIES.
HUH-UH.
>> Chris: POINTS.
KURT.
>> THEIR QUEEN IS NAMED LATIFAH.